Five days left to enroll in the
decentralized applications course.
Lincoln's description,
hello world.
It's a Raj or as my computer generated
version would say hello world.
It's Siraj.
I don't know how well you could hear that,
but that was the generated version
of my voice. He says a lot of things.
What is this madness?
This is crazy.
I like to travel.
He says a lot,
but basically he has a deep learning
generated version of my boys.
The Demo for today is going to
be us generating our own voices.
What I just played was this web app
called liar bird behind the hood.
They're using what's called a an encoder
decoder architecture to generate voices
after having trained on your voices.
So definitely check that out.
It's called liar bird.
Got Ai,
but we're going to talk
about the technology that it
uses and it uses something
that is very similar to
what Baidu released recently
by new recently released a
paper called neuro voice cloning and
it's really rare for any of these big
Chinese companies like 10 cent or Alibaba
or Baidu to release something open
source.
So I'm very grateful.
We should all be very grateful and we
should find ways to incentivize these
companies to share more of their
findings because China is really, really,
really going in on AI and we want
to see more open source work, uh,
from that region of the world. So, uh,
what we're gonna do is we're
going to talk about deep voice,
one deep voice to the points three and
then the latest version of the boys,
which is by dues,
um,
text to speech system
called neural voice cloning.
Basically you can say something and then
translate it into somebody else's voice.
Like Kate Winslet for example. That's
why I had the picture of Kate Winslet,
one of the authors of this,
this get hub library that
we're going to look at later.
He translated his voice
into Kate Winslet's voice.
So you could say something,
enter it into the system, and then Kate
Winslet will say the exact same thing.
That right. So, and we're going to look
at the code as well. It's tentraflow code.
We're going to figure out
how this architecture works,
how it's evolved over the past two years
at Baidu has been working on this and
hopefully you'll get an idea of how
you yourself can do this as well.
The link to the get hub repo is going
to be in a video description. Okay,
so let's, let's go into
this. So deep voice one,
so in February of last year by do
released the voice by do by the way,
is like China's version of Google.
It's like the biggest Chinese company
as focusing on deep learning right now.
But they released a
system called deep voice,
and what it was was a
production grade system.
That means that means that it was a
system that was made for use in production
environments for people to actually
use that apply deep learning to text,
to speech synthesis.
That means you type a sentence
and then a computer then reads,
it reads that sentence and it
says what that sentence is, right?
So the traditional tts,
Texas speech pipeline
consists of hand engineering,
all these features of like
what a boy sounds like,
what a single word sounds like,
et cetera.
But deep learning does away with feature
engineering, as you probably know,
if not, it does away with it and said it
learns all the features that it needs.
And so the system can be trained
and retrained and just a few hours.
And here's the, here's the really
interesting bit by new clamp,
a 400 x speedup over wavenet.
So wave net was deep minds really
kick ass paper of the year last year,
uh,
on tts systems.
And that's a 400 x speedup on the
world's leading AI institution,
which has really impressive. It's
true. It's very impressive. So yeah,
China, we gotta, we gotta,
we gotta get in on China Sea,
see what's going down in China.
You know what I'm saying? So, uh,
so let's talk about this architecture.
So what they use was an encoder decoder
architecture who was inspired by famous
paper called sequence to sequence
learning that came out of Google.
But the model looks like this.
Here's what the pipeline looks like.
So you say something, right? You say
something, it could be like, hello world,
it's Raj. And then it, it has
a text version of that, right?
So there's a text version and what
it does is the model will burst.
It'll take that text,
right? All of those words,
and it will convert those words
into what are called phonemes.
Phonemes are the way of describing
what a word sounds like. So here's,
here's what I mean by that. So think
about the words though. And then rough.
They both end in this, O u g H,
right? But they sound different.
So how do we represent that
for a computer to read, right?
So the way we represent that,
that is by using what are called phonemes,
and there are dictionaries
of phonemes online. So a,
so check this out the word,
the phrase white room in the phony
version of that is w a y one.
So [inaudible] means a certain way of
saying Hii. Cc the sound here. Ahi.
When we say it in the context of white,
it makes a certain sound like hi,
right white. But if we say Hii in
another context, like hi, it's different,
it's hi, instead of I rights,
there's an h in front of it.
So we could differentiate
that using phonemes.
So one would be like a one and then
another would be [inaudible], right?
So it's different than just saying like,
here's what those letters are
that consists of the word,
here's what it sounds like.
So the first part of the model would
convert the text into the phonemes, right?
Once it had the phonemes and would use
another model to convert those phonemes
into a prediction of what the duration
was of those phonemes and in the
frequency of those phonemes as well.
So how long do we say those
phonemes in the context of, uh,
of a sentence, right? How long does that
phony molasses, right. It could be small,
it can be long and there's,
you know, it could,
it could be a millisecond difference,
but there's still a duration for how
long it is. Frequency means intonation.
Like how high, how low? Think about
languages like Mandarin, right?
Intonation matters. Like, you know,
there's like four tones in Mandarin, like,
you know, like that. So, uh, tone matters,
duration matters. And then lastly,
once it had all three of those things,
right, it had the phoneme count,
it had the duration,
it had the frequency,
it combined all of those
and fed it to a decoder.
And what the decoder would do would be,
it would reconstruct the original audio,
but in the context of the original voice,
right?
So you have some text,
it predicts all of these three features,
and then it's going to
construct the voice.
So what would the spoken
version of the text,
the, and that's what it did.
It wasn't converting anything
into a different voice,
it was just reading the text.
But this was a really cool model.
And the second step, like I said, was
predicted durations and frequencies.
And by the way,
the way they did this,
the way they predicted the durations
and frequencies frequencies by,
is by using that model in the
middle that we talked about up here.
But that model in the middle is
calledF segmentation model because it's
segmented the audio clips
of each, uh, phony, right?
So you've got the audio of the text,
you at the phoneme that we're
feeding into the segmentation model,
and it will map one to the other.
Once we've got those,
we'll combine the phonemes of durations
and the frequencies to output a sound
wave that represents the text.
So they,
they'd model this after deep mines.
Wavenet so they were inspired by
deep minds wavenet architecture,
which looks like this.
So the deepmind wavenet architecture,
we can make an entire video. In
fact, I, I have one on this. Uh,
it's called generating music using
tensorflow. So check out that one.
So wavelets architecture is really
interesting because it's able to say,
how am I supposed to pronounce this in
the context of what I'm about to say?
So it uses what's called an intention
mechanism to look at the input data and
say,
okay,
so let's say we're trying to have a
system that generates a speech of hello
world. It's a garage. It's going to
look at the word Saroj in the future.
To see how it should
pronounce hello world hits.
Because you know how phrases like
they depend on like the, there's,
there's a kind of flow,
like an intonation flow when it comes to
phrases and saying something is always
dependent on what else you're saying,
if that makes sense. So in a sentence,
you're saying a couple of words and the
intonation of later words depends on the
intonation of previous words.
It's kind of complicated,
but it's basically looking at the
future to try to predict the past.
And that's the attention
mechanism in this case.
But basically it was an encoder
decoder architecture that's,
it had two different models and then in
a few months later they released what's
called deep voice to basically, it was a
same model, but they just scaled it up,
meeting they,
they train it on even more speakers.
So they were the scale ups from 20
hours of speech and a single voice to
hundreds of hours of speech
with hundreds of voices.
And each voice corresponds to a
single vector. So about 50 numbers,
which summarize how to generate sounds
that imitate the target speaker. Right.
So if we have some targets, speaker like
me, we train this model on my voice,
it's going to generate a single vector
and that means a matrix with 50 different
numbers in there. That's it.
And that represents my voice.
And from that the model can generate
my voice like what we just did,
which is really incredible. So then deep
voice three was a couple months later,
so nearing like closer to closer to now,
which they said let's,
let's do away with that model.
Let's create a new model.
And it trained an order
of magnitude faster and it
allowed them to scale to over
800 hours of training data.
Even more voices. 2,400 voices.
Yes.
So it looked like this. So it was still
a sequence to sequence model, right?
It had an encoder and it had a decoder.
But the difference was that
it uses convolutional blocks.
So recall that convolutional networks
are used for image processing. However,
if you look in papers recently,
convolutional blocks are being used
more and more in a sequence learning in
general,
right in recurrent networks and in coder
decoder architectures because they'd
done so well.
Our CNN for example,
was used by Facebook research
recently to map someone's body in a,
in a video and then turn it into
a three d model in real time.
So convolutional networks are being used
more and more in sequence learning like
sequences.
In that case would the brand of a video
and what they use was a low
dimensional speaker embedding.
So they represented every single speaker
with a different embedding and once
they,
once they had that embedding,
they could retrain the model
into somebody else's voice,
which is kind of what led
up to neuro boys cloning,
which is their most recent paper,
which came out just a few weeks ago.
So neural flow voice cloning
is really impressive.
It's really impressive because it was an
example of few shot generative modeling
of speech. That means that using
only a few samples of my voice,
like a few sentences,
it will be able to then generate
speech in the style of meat.
So it's like style transfer,
right?
Taking van Gogh's paintings and
applying it to a novel paintings,
but doing it for speech.
And not only doing that but doing
it with just a few examples,
which is incredible. It's incredible.
Right? So let's check this out. So,
so what they did was they said,
let's segment this problem
into two different categories.
There's speech speaker adoption
and then their speaker encoding.
So Speaker adaption is saying,
let's say I want to say something
in the style of Kate Winslet.
Speaker adoption is the
problem of saying I'm, I'm,
I'm going to say something to this model.
It's going to listen and then it's going
to output something in the style of
Kate Winslet.
But in order to do that,
it's got to have an embedding
a representation vector,
essentially a vector of what I sound like.
Remember that Matrix with 50 numbers
in it that represents the Rod.
That is an example of speaker adoption.
How do we train a model to
adapt to not only my voice,
but to Kate Winslet scores? And then
there's a problem of speaker and coding.
How do we encode my voice? How do we
represent my voice into that matrix?
So segmenting the problem into those
two different problems helped them build
this model. So in the case of
speaker adoption, what that,
what it meant for them was fine tuning
a multi-speaker generative model with a
few Connie examples and they train
the whole thing using backpropagation.
So it was using backpropagation
for both the encoder and a decoder.
And so what they found was when they
mapped out all the speaker embeddings that
they learned from all the different
speakers that they trained on,
they found that,
uh,
there were clusters around
speakers who had the sim, how,
who had similar regional dialects.
There were also clusters around
speakers who had similar genders,
males and females,
or clustered together.
So males from a specific region all
cluster together in terms of where they
weren't in this latent space. Right?
This embedding space, the learn space,
which is really cool
if you think about it.
There's a lot we can learn from that
in terms of how language works and how
different people relate to each other
in terms of their language and where
they're from. So there's that and
it was called neuro voice synthesis.
So I thought, okay, cool. Let's
see, let's see what we can do here.
Obviously they haven't really started
code, but they did release the paper.
I took a look at the paper. It's a
really good paper, check it out. Uh,
links are going to be in the description,
but liar bird was a way for us to,
you know, really do
this with a web app. Uh,
there's also this really great repository
that I found. Um, it's uh, it's all,
it's only four months old,
so it's relatively new.
And their architecture is very
similar to neural voice cloning,
which is why I picked it for this video.
But basically they had two networks,
right?
Just like the neuro voice clinic,
like an encoder decoder type architecture.
So the first network is an encoder
and the second one is a Dakota.
We can also think of it as the
first network being a classifier.
And the second network being
a synthesizer or a generator.
Let's just look at the code here.
So I've downloaded the code and
we're going to look at it right now.
So under models our pie, we can
see some of the codes. So let's,
let's make this bigger and, and see
what, see what's going on here. Okay,
so they've got two networks here.
They've got network one and network too,
and they're trained sequentially.
So we've,
we're first going to train network one
and then we're going to try network to in
this code. So network one is
going to act as a classifier.
What they did was they trained it
on what's called a timid dataset.
These are 630 speakers with
the label being the, uh,
phonemes for each speaker, right? So if
a speaker says, you know, hello world,
it's Raj.
The label for that input data
is going to be h e y l two,
right? The phonemes for the,
for that, for those words.
And when it comes to
input data with labels,
it's a form of supervised learning.
So what the first network
did was essentially it was
just learning the mapping
between the input data and the phoneme,
right?
So then if you give it some novel speaker
like who, who it's never seen before,
it'll be able to predict what
the phonemes are over time.
So remember in neural networks are just
a series of matrix operations, right?
And these are just numbers and operations
that are being applied to and using
some optimization scheme
like backpropagation or
whatever genetic algorithms,
it will slowly update the
wait values over time.
So that that whenever
we have some input data,
it's going to hit the right numbers
in those matrices to then output the,
the most likely prediction,
right?
Over time it's going to be
trained by minimizing the error,
like how far off it is
from the actual label.
So when you give it some novel speaker,
it's never seen before,
it's able to predict what the
phonemes would be just because, uh,
there's a likelihood that it's going to
be that based on what I've seen before.
So if we look at this
for the first network,
it first loads up that vocabulary right?
The phoneme to Idx,
to a phoneme IDX to phoneme.
And basically that those are
the labels and the phonemes,
like the words and the phone names for
all those speakers. And then it does some,
it does a form of data preprocessing by
using a very small neural network just
to make sure that the data is normalized.
So they called that a pre net.
Then once it's, once it's
got that a normalized data,
it feeds it to the network.
So they call it here
in this code C, B H, g.
But if we look in the, uh, modules
CBHD, uh, it's actually just
a convolutional network,
right? So it's just, uh,
it's just layers of convolutions
over and over and over again.
Accomplish one normalized convolution to
normalize pollution, three normalized.
And then if we go back to the models,
we'll see that, okay, it's, it's,
it's got the input data, it's got the
labels and it has the, it has the output,
right? So what is it predicted
label? And then lastly,
it does a final linear projection
by using a fully connected layer.
This is usually,
this is like a very common thing in
neural networks to have your last layer of
your network actually just be fully
connected or a dense layer in the case of
tensorflow,
a soft Max and then output a class
probability and then the predictions are
going to be formatted using two and
32 and then we return all of those,
right?
So that's the first step to train this
first network on the input data and the
phonemes. And once we've got
that fully trained network,
then we can train the next network.
By the way,
the loss function they're using for that
person network is cross entropy loss,
which means we're just going to do them
essentially the mean squared error.
That's just a different way of saying
mean squared error taking the mean of the,
of the uh,
actual,
the prediction minus the
actual label squaring it.
And then returning that for the
second network. It's going to say, oh,
we've got the first network
train knowledge generates
some new, some new audio,
right?
So how is it going to do this?
So when it comes to the new audio that
what they used was they used some speaker
Dataset.
So for Kate Winslet,
they used two hours of audio books
read by Kate Winslet. Okay, so,
so what I mean is they said,
let's first input what Caitlin's s says,
that wave form into the first model,
right? So it's a fully trained model.
They fed the, what Kate Winslet said, not
what the timid data sets speaker said,
what Kate Winslet said to
that fully trained model.
Now what's it going to output
after having been trained?
It's going to output the
phonemes. Exactly, yes.
Once it's got the phonemes
for what Kate wins, we'll say,
then it's going to feed those phonemes
to this second network, right?
Which is the speech synthesizer network.
Again,
it's going to do some data processing
using this pre network again,
and then it's going to feed it to the
same kind of convolutional network, right?
It's, it's a similar convolutional
network, but it's in the reverse, right?
So remember neural networks are just
a series of matrix operations, right?
You have some input data,
you do some majors multiplication,
you do an activation function and then
you repeat and everything's really a
glorified version of that.
And this just matrix multiplication
over and over and over and over again.
And when it comes to deep learning,
research,
deep learning research is this playing
around with what types of operations
we're using, what sequence we're doing
those operations in. And in the end,
some of the best models are
just researchers playing
around with what should
come first or should we try
this multiplication here
or should we divide this
and then use the mean? There's this
great xkcd where the guy's just like,
how'd your deep learning model works
so well? And the other guys just like,
I don't know,
I just jumbled up all this linear Algebra
together and it made us great output.
And it's basically the appointing
research in a nutshell.
When it comes to the second network,
it was able to generate
audio from the phonemes.
So the way it did that was it use
a different type of loss function.
And the different types of the different
types of loss function was called a
reconstruction loss.
So we could see it right here.
So it use a reconstruction loss.
It had the phonemes and using those
phonemes it applied the series of majors
operations in this convolutional network
that at first it knew nothing, right?
So it's just that Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah.
Here's the output, a jumble of numbers.
And so that jumble of numbers,
they compared it to the original
what Kate Winslet set, right?
What did it, what it Kaywin's that
originally say that's the actual outputs.
So then it computer or
reconstruction laws,
which is how well could it reconstruct
what Kate Winslet said from the phonemes
that were generated from the first model.
You see what I'm saying?
It fed what Kate ones.
I said to the first model output phonemes
phonemes to the second model output,
what the, the reconstructed
version of what Caitlin's and say,
which is actually just a bunch of numbers
at first and compared that output to
what Kate ones, it's voice originally
was that the reconstruction error,
they'll the loss between those
and it used that difference.
And it minimized that difference over
time using backpropagation. Okay.
So over time then the second model was
able to better reconstruct the Kaywin's.
It's voice over time.
Now that's just Kate Winslet.
If we kept beating at different speakers,
it will learn multiple speakers, right?
So it could reconstruct all of
those different speakers over time.
But they just fed Kate Winslet.
So eventually right after
training both models in that way.
So the first was a classifier
trained using cross entropy loss.
The second was a generator and the loss
was instead of reconstruction loss,
the first was trained
on a million speakers.
The second was trade on just Kate Winslet.
So then if I say something,
it will go through the first, create a
phoneme, list that peanut to the second,
and then you'll reach, you'll reconstruct
it as Kate Winslet after training.
So that's, that's how they did that.
And they did it using tensorflow.
The model works, um, the guy even has
a, a demo of it as well, work with,
and where can we see them? It's
on soundcloud, you called it.
What's the culture of the revolution
thus far? Had exhausted the young cub
it's seems,
yeah, you can check out the demo there
as well, but yeah, pretty cool stuff.
All the lengths that up,
the stuff I've talked about are going to
be in the video description and I hope
you found this video useful.